30 octobre 1938 un frisson d'angoissé
traverse les états unis à la radio on
annonce en direct une invasion martienne
heureusement c'était un canular pour
halloween mais quelques personnes y ont
cru forgeant la légende de la planète
mars vous dire qu'à l'époque on ne
savait pas s'il y avait de la vie ou non
là où tout était encore possible
eh bien figurez-vous que 80 ans plus
tard on n'a toujours pas répondu à la
question on sait qu'il ya pas de
soucoupe volante mais on pense avoir
trouvé d'anciennes traces organiques
mais qu'est ce que ça implique deux buts
on croit ton qu'il ya de la vie sur mars
egypte grèce mais hop au tamis mars
fascine depuis longtemps mais c'est
seulement grâce au premier télescope du
xviie siècle qu'on commence à savoir à
quoi elle ressemble et déjà en 1656 pour
la première fois de l'histoire un acteur
s'imagine la visite est guidée par un
ange
c'était alors une planète volcanique
indé royaume de dieu là je vais vous
étonner mais malgré la religion très tôt
dans l'histoire on se dit qu'il ya de la
vie là haut vous dire que la planète
ressemble beaucoup à la nôtre de la
glace au niveau des pôles et un rythme
jour nuit quasi identique en 1869 le
terme martiens et à monter et des romans
décrivent des sociétés intelligente
extraterrestre
côté sciences et la folie aussi en 1877
avec les progrès de l'optique on est
maintenant capable de dessiner les
reliefs de la planète on y découvre et
ligne étrange des canali comme si on
avait tenté d riguelle sol pour faire de
l'agriculture le monde s'enflamme il y à
là bas des formes de vie intelligente si
au début les martiens sont représentés
comme une race humaine supérieur c'est
avec la guerre des mondes en 1897 qui
deviennent des monstres prêts à envahir
la terre et nous réduire en esclavage
dans un contexte violent
d'industrialisation et colonisation
c'est en fait l'occident qui renvoie ses
propres peurs sur elle même et ce livre
on sous-estimé à quel point est là pour
toujours bouleversée l'imaginaire du
monde le temps passé dans les années 50
ça se précise les scientifiques avant
que le concept de zone habitable une
planète ne doit pas 3 de près de son
soleil sinon l'eau s'évapore et pas trop
éloigné non plus sinon elle gèle il se
trouve que comme la terre mars et dans
la gold il auxonne aujourd'hui on sait
que ce concept n'est pas tout à fait
vrai déjà on sous-estiment beaucoup le
rôle de l'effet de serre de la chaleur
emprisonné dans l'atmosphère par des gaz
comme le co2 ou la vapeur d'eau ça a
l'air d'être un mot méchant mais en fait
sans effet de serre la terre serait à
moins 18 degrés merci le réchauffement
climatique mais aussi europe la lune de
jupiter qui a un véritable océan sous
son épaisse couche de glace qu'on peut
parfois admirer dans d'immenses déserts
dos de la vie pourrait aussi être
développées même si on est loin de la
zone habitable le concept a tout de même
permis de faire rêver les scientifiques
du monde entier il ne manquait plus que
le financement et ça tombait bien car on
était en pleine guerre froide c'était la
course à l'armement et à la science
découvrir la vie sur mars était la
certitude d'entrer dans l'histoire pour
l'éternité à votre avis qui est arrivé
le premier l'urss y va à fond les cinq
premiers essais c'est eu que des échecs
finalement c'est les états unis avec
marine eur 4 en 1965 qui sont les
premiers à survoler mars ont fait les
premiers clichés de sa surface et c'est
le choc des cratères par milliers une
atmosphère 100 fois inférieures à la
terre une température en dessous de zéro
et pas de champs magnétiques pour se
protéger des radiations cosmiques pour
une forme de vie développé en surface
c'est mal barré mais des scientifiques
et quoi encore on peut peut-être trouvé
des bactéries mais pour ça il faut
atterrir donc la course reprend et
l'urss est bien décidé à briller et 2,1
et 2,2 et 2,3 les échecs de lancement
s'enchaînent miracle en novembre 71 mars
2 et mars trois sont enfin prêts à se
poser
le premier s'écrase et le deuxième à
terry mais perd le contact après 14
secondes pas assez de temps pour finir
la transmission de ce qui aurait pu être
la première photo de mars il retente
avec mars 4 5 6 7 encore des échecs
c'est encore les américains qui gagnent
avec l'atterrisseur vikings en 1976
explications de mou depuis hier la sonde
américaine viking est en orbite autour
de mars si tout se passe bien dans une
quinzaine de jours les responsables
américains déclencheront l'atterrissage
sur mars d'un des compartiments de
l'engin on pourra alors peut être
répondre à cette question la vie existe
t-elle sur la planète voici enfin la
première photo du sol martien de
l'histoire et c'est quand même une
deuxième déception aucune trace de vie
tout cet argent vous rien n'en soyons
pas si sûr comment sait-on qu'il ya de
l'eau sur mars oui il y à de l'eau sur
mars beaucoup d'eau mais les conditions
de température et de pression sont
telles qu'on en retrouve quasi
uniquement sous forme de glace on peut
l'observer par exemple au niveau des
pôles avec d'énormes étendue de glace
souvent mélangées avec du co2 solide de
la glace carbonique comme dante et
cocktails mais ça c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui mais est ce que le liquide
n'a pas pu exister avant et donc
potentiellement la vie car on peut le
savoir en étudiant une forme très
spécial de l'eau je vous explique vous
le savez l'eau ch2o un atome d'oxygène
lié à deux hydrogène dans la nature
l'hydrogène peut être radioactives quant
à neutrons se colle aux protons de
l'hydrogène ça donne du deutérium qui
peut prendre la place du hb dans l'eau
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'eau lourde
naturellement radioactives et sur mars
commencent à se formeraient et bien
grâce à des rayonnements intense du
soleil pouvant casser les liaisons de la
molécule d'eau l'hydrogène trop léger
pour être maintenue par la gravité va
directement s'échapper dans l'atmosphère
ce n'est pas le cas du deutérium plus
lourds qui va pouvoir se lier aux deux
oxygène orpheline si ça arrive mars père
alors une molécule dont vous avez
compris plus l'hydrogène des molécules
d'eau s'échappe plus des isotopes liés
au deutérium se forment et bingo il a
été estimé que la concentration de
deutérium sur mars est six fois plus
importante que sur terre il y a eu de
l'eau sur mars beaucoup d'eau ayant fini
par disparaître à travers les milliards
d'années qui nous sépare c'était il ya 4
milliards d'années est ce que vous voyez
est dû de simulation de la nasa et en
observant la surface de mars on peut
même en retrouver des traces regardez ça
vous fait penser à quoi des lits de
rivières totalement asséché ces fameux
canaux sur lesquels on avait tant
fantasmer il ya 150 ans des anciens
réseaux où se seraient écoulés de l'eau
liquide durant des millions d'années
hypothèse d'ailleurs renforcé par la
découverte d'argile lors de missions
récentes minéraux se formant uniquement
par le lessivage de roches silicatées
par lots situés en surface encore mieux
regarder la moitié de l'hémisphère nord
est très différente du sud il y a une
pleine parfaitement lisse ça pourrait
être les restes d'un giga océan océane
us boréalis qui couvrait le 20 % de mars
dans cette zone par exemple pourrait
avoir été une vallée dans laquelle un
fleuve se seraient déversés dans l'océan
ces écoulements en serait la preuve que
le climat martien a été dans le passé
totalement différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui un climat plus chaud
permettant le maintien de l'eau sous
forme liquide durant des millions
d'années c'est bien beau tout ça mais
c'était il ya 4 milliards d'années il
s'est passé quoi depuis le problème
vient du champ magnétique il a disparu
et sans cette protection contre les
vents solaires l'atmosphère a commencé à
s'échapper de la traction de mars les
particules très énergétiques viennent se
frotter à l'atmosphère en propulsant des
petits bouts dans l'espace 100 grammes
par seconde plus de 3000 tonnes par an
sur des milliards d'années un phénomène
qui est accentuée par la faible gravité
de mars dix fois moins lourde que celle
sur terre mais alors si les conditions
sont idéales pour voir l'adie émerger
dans le passé le ton a retrouvé des
traces comment sait-on s'il y a eu de
l'addition mars 2012 le rover curiosity
atterri dans le cratère de gail un
ancien lac où repose un vaste du de
sédiments jamais on a découvert une si
grande variété de molécules organiques
la base même des êtres vivants ou alors
est-ce que ça suffit pour dire qu'il ya
eu de la vie non comme on l'a vu dans
cette vidéo même s'il existe un grand
nombre de molécules organiques liés aux
vivants elles peuvent également en être
indépendantes se formant à partir des
réactions chimiques naturelles le cas le
plus débattu et la détection de méthane
sur mars sur terre il est considéré
comme un indicateur d'activité
biologique est mis en grande partie par
les bactéries mais sur mars d'autres
souffrent sont également envisageables
et ce à partir de réaction abiotique et
on n'est pas aidés on a retrouvé sur
mars qu une faible diversité de
molécules organiques est en faible
quantité par rapport à quoi on
s'attendait et cette raison ces
centaines de milliers de cratères que
l'on retrouve à sa surface chaque point
rouge de cette image montre un impact de
moins un kilomètre de diamètre sur mars
par des météorites ils sont plus de six
cent trente cinq mille est encore bien
plus en considérant les plus petites
mars été littéralement bombardé durant
des milliards d'années si je vous parle
de ces météorites ce n'est pas pour rien
l'analyse de météorites écrasé sur terre
a permis de découvrir une grande variété
de molécules organiques comme des bases
azotées la base de notre adn
récapitulons si plusieurs milliers de
tonnes de matière organique avait été
apportée sur mars pendant une période où
les conditions auraient été favorables à
l'émergence de la vie dans un scénario
idéal tous ces ingrédients aurait permis
la mise en place d'une chimie
prébiotique similaire à celle sur terre
mais malheureusement les molécules
organiques en surface qu'on pourrait
relier à de la vie passée n'existe déjà
plus 4 milliards d'années de rayonnement
solaire intense ça détruit tout ajoutez
à ça une chine et agressive causés par
des composés occident comme des sels de
perchlorate ou des oxydes de fer en
abondant sur mars pour pallier à ce
problème une des solutions serait de
creuser en profondeur pour atteindre
d'estrade préserver et c'est justement
la mission de rosalind franklin la
nouvelle génération de rover envoyé pour
la première fois par l'europe pour la
mission exomars 2022 mais déjà reporté à
cause de la pandémie en 2020 elle a
encore une nouvelle fois été mise en
arrêt depuis le conflit avec la russie
et oui c'est eux qui préparait le
lanceur si tout s'était bien passé lors
over aurait dû atterrir en juin 2000 23
dans le bassin hawks à plat noom anciens
lacs et zones à fort potentiel de
contenir de la matière organique et ce à
l'aide de foreuses pouvant creuser
jusqu'à deux mètres de profondeur
l'analyse des données sera longue
surtout qu'on ne cherche peut-être pas
les bonnes molécules si la vie a été
très différentes sur mars par rapport à
la terre n utilise potentiellement pas
les mêmes briques de la dit que nous
autre problème les limites des machines
la taille fortement limité par les
lanceurs on n'aura jamais les mêmes
instruments d'analysé ultra précis qu'on
a sur terre voilà pourquoi on pense déjà
à l'après ramener des échantillons sur
terre qui permettrait des analyses
biologiques beaucoup plus poussés par
exemple étudié la qualité des molécules
dont on a parlé sur notre vidéo comment
créer la vie depuis zéro c'est ce qui va
se passer pour le rover persévérance
déjà sur place et les premiers retours
sont attendus pour minimum 2030 si vous
avez été si patient pour attendre la
sortie de zelda brax et wild 2 vous êtes
déjà bien armé
pourquoi dépenser autant d'argent pour
si peu je dois vous avouer que si demain
on découvre qu'il ya de la vie sur mars
on risque un peu de s'en [ __ ] en fait
ça fait des années qu'on parle de ce
truc l'effet de surprise est un peu
passée dans une société où la science
est partout où il ya moins ce besoin de
prouver que nous ne sommes pas les seuls
dans l'univers même les religions
l'admettre aujourd'hui nous ne serions
pas les seules créatures de dieu dans
l'univers preuve de sa grandeur alors
est ce qu'on va dire comme sur twitter
qu'il faudrait mettre l'argent du
spatial dans la réduction des inégalités
ou la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
non les efforts que nous faisons pour
aller sur mars ce sont des technologies
qui se retrouvent dans nos vies qui
aideront le futur à être meilleurs et
pourquoi pas commencer à habiter
ailleurs que sur terre le destin de mars
c'est tout ce que nous voulons éviter
chez nous il y a des réponses à trouver
là-bas par exemple saviez-vous que
l'absence d'activité tectoniques sur
place nous a permis de retrouver des
roches datant de plusieurs milliards
d'années époque dont on n'en trouve plus
aucune trace sur terre c'est un
formidable témoignage pour comprendre la
jeunesse de notre planète alors
continuons de rêver comme nos anciens
ceux qui croyaient là-haut trouver des
sociétés utopique ou biberon de la même
soif de connaissance simplement
aujourd'hui on peut se permettre de
viser les étoiles